die zahl steigt deutlich zum ersten mal
registrieren die gesundheitsämter mehr
als 11.000 corona infektionen an einem
tag tschechien fährt runter weil sich
das virus so schnell ausbreitet soll
niemand mehr ohne wichtigen grund seine
wohnung verlassen und vor der letzten
tv-debatte us-präsident am kämpft um
seine wiederwahl sein vorgänger obama
wirbt für herausforderer bei
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem donnerstag an meiner seite ist
für den sport norbert könnte gerne
genommen die lage ist ernst aber wir
sind nicht machtlos so hat es heute der
präsident des robert koch-instituts
zusammengefasst ein großteil der
menschen stecke sich im privaten umfeld
an
deswegen sei es wichtiger denn je auch
dort die regeln einzuhalten
erstmals seit beginn der korona pandemie
wurden in deutschland an einem tag mehr
als 11.000 fälle registriert aktuell
werden 943 menschen mit coupies 19
intensivmedizinisch behandelt
das sind doppelt so viele wie vor zwei
wochen volker check mit details über
nacht macht baesweiler bei aachen
schlagzeilen auf die alle gerne
verzichtet hätten 321 neuinfektionen pro
100000 einwohner nach privaten
veranstaltungen für familienfeiern oder
auch besucher zu einer beerdigung in der
region und die rückkehrer haben dann die
krankheit mitgebracht
baesweiler liegt im bundesweiten trend
das bestätigen die zahlen vom
robert-koch-institut haupt ansteckung
sword sind jetzt privat feiern und das
private umfeld hier in blau und nicht
mehr der arbeitsplatz wie zu zeiten der
fleischfabrik infektion im juni viele
passen auch bei freizeitaktivitäten
besser auf in den letzten 30 wochen hat
sich die ansteckung mehr und mehr in
richtung privater haushalte und auch
wieder alten und pflegeheime verlagert
wenn wir also umsichtig sind besonders
auch in geschlossenen räumen da stecken
wir uns weniger an und da stecken wir
auch unsere familienmitglieder und
mitbewohner weniger an und das ist die
gute nachricht meine damen und herren
wir können viel dazu selber beitragen
anstecken zu verhindern
die vorteile der aha + l regeln preist
wiler seit monaten an abstand halten
hygienevorschriften alltags schutzmasken
und natürlich stoßlüften um die
schädlichen aerosole an die luft zu
setzen
die nachverfolgung der infektionsketten
in den gesundheitsämtern ist aus sicht
des rk ii das einzige mittel weitere
ansteckungen zu unterbinden
die bundeswehr ist schon da der
bundesinnenminister kündigt weitere
hilfen für die länder an
auch bei der kontrolle der korona
maßnahmen wir werden am wochenende auch
deshalb hierfür berlin massiv
bundespolizei zur verfügung stellen auf
bitten des landes berlin um die
einhaltung der regeln auch zu
gewährleisten
mit hamsterkäufen gegen ohnmachtsgefühle
so interpretieren jedenfalls psychologen
den wieder sprunghaft gestiegenen absatz
von toilettenpapier
die menschen kauften im oktober doppelt
so viel papier wie vor corinna werde es
gehört nach angaben des lka sind die
privaten kontakte im moment der
hauptgrund für den rasanten anstieg der
korona zahlen vor allem junge leute
seien da gefordert
jetzt zeigt aber eine neue studie die 16
bis 26 jährigen sind
verantwortungsbewusster und
solidarischer als manche glauben
so findet über die hälfte der befragten
die korona maßnahmen angemessen und 83
prozent halten sich daran
vor allem um die gesundheit anderer zu
schützen ein fünftel hält die
beschränkungen für übertrieben elisabeth
schmidt über jugend in corona zeiten
gemeinsam sport machen
monatelang war das für die jugendlichen
der turnerschaft in großburgwedel bei
hannover corona bedingt nicht möglich
nur die da oben in der politik
interessierten ihre sorgen und
bedürfnisse wenig diesen eindruck hat
laut tüv studie knapp die hälfte der
jugendlichen
ich könnte mir schon vorstellen dass der
politik vielleicht die wirtschaft etwas
wichtiger ist als jetzt das miteinander
in den sportverein aber das ist halt so
was was uns jungen leuten dann fehlt
dass man sich nicht mit seinen freunden
treffen kann
jetzt habe ich nur meine eltern haben
beide systemrelevanten jobs und die
werden irgendwie bezahlt aber viele
meiner freunde haben das glück nicht
die studie fragte die jugendlichen auch
danach was ihnen bei den chor ohne
einschränkungen besonders schwer fiel
42% vermissten ihre sozialkontakte 40
prozent fehlten freizeitaktivitäten wie
sport 29 prozent private oder
öffentliche feiern
die überwiegende mehrheit hält sich nach
eigener
angaben an die hygieneregeln auch um
andere zu schützen
doch junge menschen kommen zur zeit eher
als corona partygänger und viren
verbreitet in die schlagzeilen
ich sehe eine große gefahr eigentlich
darin dass man die jugendlichen so als
eine art sündenbock darstellt dass wir
die solidarität die die jungen
erwachsenen ja eigentlich schon bereit
sind zu zeigen in der korona pandemie
dass wir die ein bisschen verspielen
indem wir einen diskurs aufmachen der
jung gegen alt heißt das sehen auch
soziologen so und mahnen nicht zu
vergessen was zur entwicklung junger
menschen gehöre grenzen austesten
freundschafts netzwerke knüpfen
beziehungen aufbauen und da gilt es dann
an politik einfach da neue strukturen zu
schaffen und unterstützung zu schaffen
dass die soziale benachteiligung nicht
immer größer werden insgesamt blicken
jugendliche etwas weniger optimistisch
in die zukunft als vor der pandemie
fielen brachen nebenjobs oder
ausbildungsplätze weg besonders hart
trifft die pandemie auch patienten im
krankenhaus und ihre angehörigen
denn viele kliniken haben wegen corona
des besuchsrechts stark eingeschränkt um
trotzdem bei ihrem schwerkranken mann
sein zu dürfen zog eine frau aus bremen
vor gericht sabine kommen und keine
class berichten
in dieser klinik ihren krebskranken
ehemann nicht besuchen zu dürfen war wie
stefanie menke unerträglich sie klagte
gegen das besuchsverbot das aus ihrer
sicht das leben ihres ehemanns
gefährdete und setzte sich durch
ich hatte in dieser ganzen situation
immer das gefühl ich lasse meinen mann
im stich ich bin ich das zulasse
das ist dass ich dass ich von ihm fern
gehalten werde dann lasse ich ihn im
stich und ich habe immer gedacht wenn er
in dieser situation wir nehmen jetzt
schlimmes passiert wenn er womöglich auf
der intensivstation verstirbt dann würde
ich meines lebens nicht mehr froh werden
ihr ehemann litt unter der chemotherapie
und darunter seine frau nicht an seiner
seite zu haben fasste er die behandlung
deshalb abgebrochen
doch das klinikum argumentiert personal
und patienten vor corona schützen zu
müssen
wir würden sehr gerne besuch zu lassen
müssen uns aber dem infektionsschutz
bogen und müssen den angehörigen und den
patienten erklären dass das momentan in
vielen fällen nicht geht frau merkel hat
vor dem bremer amtsgericht geklagt
daraufhin die außergerichtliche einigung
die ehefrau bekam ein eingeschränktes
besuchsrecht patientenverbände fordern
die anliegen beider seiten zu
berücksichtigen
ein scheinwerfer dem wir im moment gar
nicht so sehr im fokus haben ist dieser
menschliche humanistische blick nämlich
wie geht das den menschen die krank sind
so abgeschnitten zu sein von der welt
und ebenso bevormunde zu sein
stephanie menke ist erleichtert die
kinder ihres ehemanns dürfen zwar
weiterhin nicht in die klinik sie selbst
aber darf ihn dreimal die woche besuchen
eine positive nachricht kommt von den
kanarischen inseln
dort ist die zahl der korona infektionen
gesunken so dass die bundesregierung
nicht mehr vor reisen dorthin wand
insgesamt aber wird die liste der korona
risikogebiete länger ab samstag kommen
unter anderem polen und die schweiz dazu
außerdem große teile italiens für die
lombardei inklusive mailand verhängen
die italienischen behörden wegen der
stark steigenden zahlen ab heute abend
ein nächtliches ausgangsverbot und
dänemark schließt
wie schon im frühjahr weitgehend die
grenzen für deutsche urlauber eines der
am stärksten betroffenen länder europas
ist unser nachbar tschechien heute
wieder mit neuem höchstwert fast 15.000
neuinfektionen bei etwa elf millionen
einwohnern ab sofort gelten dort strikte
maßnahmen fast alle geschäfte und hotels
müssen schließen
die menschen sollen ihre kontakte aufs
nötigste reduzieren
britta hilpert vier mal häufiger als
noch anfang des monats liefert in dieser
woche die ambulanz cupid patienten ein
nur eine zahl die belegt china
tschechien am limit steht
die regierung hat das ausland bereits um
hilfe gebeten und die kliniken selbst
gehen auch neue wege
uns fehlt einfach personal wir brauchen
freiwillige und zeitarbeiter die unsere
permanente belegschaft unterstützen
wir stellen nun auch studenten in
tschechien kommen 651 infektionen auf
100000 einwohner in sieben tagen das ist
ein trauriger spitzenplatz in europa
nach mathematischen berechnungen so
erklärte ministerpräsident barbisch
würde unser gesundheitssystem ohne
massnahmen zwischen dem siebten und
elften november zusammenbrechen masken
pflicht herrscht nun über bewegung
draußen und treffen mit anderen sind auf
ein minimum beschränkt und alle nicht
lebensnotwendigen leben sind seit heute
6 uhr geschlossen
ich bin unternehmer und es ist ein
riesenproblem
ich leide stark unter den maßnahmen sagt
der freiberufler josef aber was sollen
wir anderes tun
am stadtrand von prag errichtet die
armee einen notruf spital
denn so streng die maßnahmen auch sind
sie wirken erst später sie rechnen
zunächst mit weiter steigenden
patientenzahlen ärztekammerpräsident
reinhardt hat mit aussagen über sinn und
zweck von alltags masken heftigen
widerspruch ausgelöst
er hatte in der zdf sendung markus lanz
von einem vermummungsverbot gesprochen
dabei gebe es keine wissenschaftliche
genc des alltags masken tatsächlich
hilfreich sein
dem widerspricht die ärztegewerkschaft
marburger bund mit verweis auf aktuelle
studien einen rücktrittsgrund sieht der
spd gesundheitspolitiker lauterbach
sollte reinhard bei seiner aussage
bleiben
corona krise mehr als 11.000
neuinfektionen heißt das zdf spezial
direkt nach uns und alles zum thema gibt
es auch online in der zdf- heute- app
nach dem tödlichen messerangriff in
dresden steigt der druck auf die
behörden
vertreter von verfassungsschutz und
polizei teilten mit der tatverdächtige
syrer sei auch am tag des anschlags
observiert worden
trotzdem hätte das verbrechen nicht
verhindert werden können
die behörden hätten keine fehler gemacht
seit 2017 galt der mann als
islamistischer gefährder
er soll anfang oktober zwei männer in
dresden mit einem messer angegriffen
haben
ein opfer starb an den verletzungen im
aktuellen rennen ums weiße haus hielt ex
präsident barack obama sich lange zurück
vergangene nacht legte er die
samthandschuhe ab und meldete sich mit
beißender kritik an seinem nachfolger
donalds ab es war obamas erster
persönlicher wahlkampfauftritt für den
demokratischen herausforderer und seinen
früheren vize-präsidenten joe biden
eines trupps hat mehr
spät aber dafür umso schärfer greift ex
präsident obama für demokrat joe biden
in den wahlkampf ein
unfähig sei präsident trump das amt
anzunehmen die pandemie hätte er nicht
eingedämmt das militär verlacht dazu
rassistische themen bedient dieser
präsident will volle anerkennung für die
wirtschaft die er geerbt hat aber null
schuldzuweisung für die pandemie die
eher ignoriert so funktioniert der job
nicht vor dem fernseher zu twittern löst
keine probleme
sein appell vor allem an schwarze und
junge geht wählen
gute umfragen für beiden dürfen nicht zu
gleichgültigkeit führen
amerika müsse wieder werte hochhalten
die aufrichtigkeit und verantwortung
die sind nicht republikanische oder
demokratische grundsätze es sind
amerikanische werte und wir müssen sie
zurückgewinnen und wieder zur mitte
unseres öffentlichen lebens machen
am abend trifft trump auf beiden im
zweiten tv duell eine stumm schaltet
aste soll dieses mal verhindern dass er
seinen kontrahenten ständig unterbricht
ich finde die stumm schaltet taste sehr
unfair und es ist schlecht dass
außenpolitik nicht diskutiert werden
soll
außerdem ist die moderatorin eine sehr
parteiische person bereits vor dem duell
kritisiert trump die bedingungen als
wolle er einer niederlage vorbauen klar
ist er wird beiden aggressiv angehen
auch mit einer stumpfen taste schon
jetzt hat polen eines der strengsten
abtreibungsgesetze europas es dürfte
künftig noch strenger werden
dafür haben die verfassungsrichter
rinnen und verfassungsrichter in
warschau heute den weg geebnet
sie sagen die abtreibung von föten mit
angeborenen fehlbildungen die den down
syndrom ist verfassungswidrig
polnische frauenrechtlerinnen laufen
sturm dagegen aus warschau natalie
steger freude bei den abtreibungsgegnern
vor dem polnischen verfassungsgericht
das hat die abtreibung von füllten mit
schwerer missbildung für
verfassungswidrig erklärt heute ist
polen ein beispiel für europa und die
welt gegner und befürworter in warschau
hoch emotional auf beiden seiten es geht
ihnen um fundamentales
frauenrechtlerinnen sind entsetzt
patientinnen in solchen situationen
haben selbstmordgedanken und können sich
nicht vorstellen das kind zu gebären
jetzt ist in polen ein
schwangerschaftsabbruch nur noch legal
im fall von vergewaltigung oder wenn
leben oder gesundheit der werdenden
mutter bedroht sind nicht bei kranken
fötus die geltende gesetzeslage
entschied das gericht
die schwangerschafts abbrüche in diesen
fällen zu lässt widerspreche dem recht
auf menschliches leben
das verfassungsgericht ist fest in
regierungshand mit dem urteil hat die
peas mit ihrer parlamentsmehrheit nun
die möglichkeit in diesen fällen
abtreibung zu kriminalisieren
schon 2016 war die nationalkonservative
regierungspartei für eine verschärfung
des abtreibungsrechts aber nach
landesweiten protesten von polinnen war
die pis zurückgerudert
die pis kann nun tatsächlich die erz
konservative wählerschaft bedienen
doch sie muss damit rechnen dass die wut
der frauen polens sie erneut unter druck
setzen wird auch internationaler protest
ist garantiert
der mordfall peggy ist einer der
mysteriösesten in der deutschen
kriminalgeschichte
nun wird er zu den akten gelegt und
damit wohl für immer ungelöst bleiben
peggy war im mai 2001 im alter von neun
jahren in oberfranken verschwunden
im fast zwei jahrzehnten sammelten die
ermittler mehr als 6000 spuren 2016
wurden teile ihres skeletts in thüringen
entdeckt ein täter konnte aber nicht
gefunden werden
die staatsanwaltschaft hat die
ermittlungen nun eingestellt jetzt zu
einem preis der den einsatz für
demokratie und menschenrechte würdigt
der sacharow-preis des europäischen
parlaments
in diesem jahr erhält ihm die
belarussische oppositionsbewegung um die
ehemalige präsidentschaftskandidatin
svetlana tschechows kaya damit soll ihr
friedlicher einsatz gegen machthaber
lukaschenko ausgezeichnet werden
christian senn berichtet seit mehr als
zwei monaten gehen die menschen jetzt in
belarus auf die straße für freiheit und
gegen machthaber lukaschenko mutige
menschen gegen einen brutal prügelnde
und repressives system nun bekommt die
demokratische opposition für ihren
friedlichen protest den sacharow preis
ich möchte den vertreterinnen und
vertretern der belarussischen opposition
danken für ihren mut für ihre
entschiedenheit für ihr vorgehen
sie verkörpern jeden tag die
verteidigung der freiheit das ist das
wofür sich der sacharow-preis einsetzt
vor allem die tapferen belarussischen
frauen haben weltweit die aufmerksamkeit
auf diese friedlichen proteste gerichtet
das führungstrio der opposition wurde
kaltgestellt veronika zepp carlo und die
selbsterklärte war siegerin swetlana
terra nostra mussten ins ausland
flüchten
maria kolesnikova landete im gefängnis
auch boll ja krawall korver
führungsmitglied des koordinierungsrates
musste das land verlassen
wir erreichen sie in polen es ist gut
dass die europäische union eine klar
artikulierte politische position
einnimmt
dazu gehört dass lukaschenko auf
internationaler ebene die anerkennung
versagt wird
svetlana tier allofs kaya widmete den
preis allen menschen in belarus geht den
gemeinsamen friedlichen kampf fortsetzen
am wochenende wird es neue proteste
geben
jetzt bist du dran mit einem
außergewöhnlich starken
champions-league-sieger rasante
spielzüge wunderbare tore der fc bayern
münchen knüpft nahtlos an die
erfolgsserie der vergangenen saison an
mit einem 4 0 gegen atletico madrid zum
auftakt der königsklasse 20 21 kingsley
kohmann in der wohl besten
vereinsmannschaft der welt der
herausragende die bayern dominanz gegen
atlético spielerisch gelingen die
schönsten kombinationen ballbehandlung
und chancenverwertung suchen
ihresgleichen
wir haben beim match plan gehabt die
mannschaft hat hervorragend hervorragend
umgesetzt wir haben vier wichtige tore
herausgespielt technisch glänzend ist
kommen auch als vorbereiter für koretz
cars 2 zu 0 den bayern gelingt einfach
alles selbst ein solches traumtor von
toni so weltmeisterlich unbeirrbar und
schier unaufhaltsam kingsley koman zum 4
0-endstand der champions-league-sieger
zeigt stärke und koma eine gute portion
extra klasse ein achtbares 2 zu 2 bei
inter mailand schafft borussia
mönchengladbach in seinem ersten
gruppenspiel der champions league aber
es war mehr drin denn jonas hofmann
bringt die borussen in der 84 minute mit
2 1 in führung doch mailands romelu
lukaku schafft mit seinem zweiten
treffer kurz vor schluss noch den
ausgleich
starkes brüderpaar aber nicht stark
genug für die deutsche konkurrenz mischa
und alexanders werde farben in köln ihr
doppel gegen die french open sieger
credit suisse in zwei sätzen verloren
dass das spiel am ende gegen sie
gelaufen war konnte man den schweres
ansehen auch wenn sie nicht oft im
doppel zusammen spielen bleibt der
ehrgeiz und den auch die french open
sieger credit suisse vorn im bild zu
spüren bekam
sie hatten mühe ihr tennis gegen die
beiden hamburger durchzubringen
schon der erste satz gegen ist wäre es
hart umkämpft 6 zu viel für das duo aus
coburg und köln das von der papierform
her ohnehin als favorit galt
im innerdeutschen duell entscheidet dann
ein break im zweiten satz die partie mit
6 4 und 7 zu 5 stehen kravis und mies
jetzt im halbfinale aber das wäre für im
einzel natürlich noch dabei sehr gut wie
populär der britische künstler banksy
ist zeigt sich an den preisen seiner
gemälde auch jetzt wieder im
auktionshaus sotheby's die vorlage
diesen klassiker des französischen
impressionisten claude monet hat banksy
bissig neu interpretiert die idylle des
gartens verwandelte er in eine illegale
müllhalde romy monnet heißt bank wies
kritik an umweltverschmutzung ins konsum
versteigert für 8,4 millionen euro
das wetter bringt viele wolken und regen
die details hat gleich ist intelli um
halb elf begrüßt sie christian sievers
im heute-journal hier übernimmt morgen
petra gerster und wir danken
ihr interesse und wünschen ihnen noch
einen unbeschwerten abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter an der
großwetterlage ändert sich wenig
überwiegend milde luft und neue
regengebiete ziehen über uns hinweg und
das heute nacht schon und im laufe des
tages morgen bis in den osten
deutschlands
schauen wir uns die kommende nacht an da
wird es regnen
unter dieser regen setzt sich weiter
nach nordosten durch am ehesten trocken
bleibt das ganze im osten und an den
küsten an der donau bildet sich erneut
nebel hier sinken die temperaturen bis
auf 7 grad ansonsten in der mitte
deutlich milder mit elf bis 14 grad neun
bis zehn grad entlang der küsten morgen
im tagesverlauf dann viel regen der sich
allmählich weiter nach nordosten
verlagert am nachmittag gibt es von
westen auflockerungen aber auch gewitter
ganz im südosten ist es aufgelockert
aber sonnig ist es an den küsten dort
temperaturen um 14 grad ansonsten am
mildesten noch im südosten bei 18 oder
ganz im westen am niederrhein
die kommenden tage etwas regen gibt es
am samstag im süden sonst ist es trocken
bei 13 bis 18 grad sonntag nach
nebelauflösung viel sonnenschein bei 20
grad
ein schöner ab